John what is the name of one woman's on
what was on well Apollo does her mom so
her aunt can only be you know that other
lady whose name I really do know but
it's it's lost among my Greek mythology
nom so just lay it on me soul sister
[Laughter]
auntie oh oh and t.o.p yeah I call her
Auntie oh sure yeah I don't know I'm
saying it correctly there's who plays
her was that Robin right oh thank God
you got that right what's the name of
the villainous scientist which one
doctor gasps or oh nothing evil Oh John
your poisons oh thank god sorry Oh John
doctor gasps is one of the multiple
choice questions in the geekdom episode
all right guys we're gonna watch today
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer and Justice
League twenty20 one announcement
breakdown in Easter eggs for the channel
Charlie emergency awesome great channel
fan subscribe to him do so now let's
check this out
[Music]
my favorite workout songs typing Wonder
Woman 1984 trailer music I got like a
three-minute version these are the
trailer the six-minute Burgess when I
listen to it our number six minutes
[Music]
[Music]
ah that's just a strategy mr. Setrakian
yeah yeah welcome back everyone is
Charlie this is gonna be my new Wonder
Woman 1984 trailer video we also have a
special of Justice League twenty20 one
announcement that's really cool and some
more Wonder Woman 1984 footage that
they're gonna be having really soon that
I'll explain so sorry to the channel be
sure to subscribe is be subscriber and
leave all your predictions for Wonder
Woman 1984 on the video so just go down
the list starting with number 5 Warner
Brothers just made a couple big
announcements about its movies for the
next year it shifted everything again by
a couple weeks some movies more than
that Wonder Woman 1984 is now going to
come out October 2nd this year instead
of August it's gonna be Tennant got
delayed by a couple weeks so all the
push everything now we can joke that
Wonder Woman 1984 is the New Mutants of
DC movies it's had at least three
different say the Thanksgiving this year
but then change their minds to October
as chaotic as that sounds
don't worry we're still gonna get to see
the movie is just being bumped by a
couple weeks into October so it's not
that bad it could have been way WAY
worse the special new Wonder Woman 1984
footage that they're gonna be releasing
is actually gonna be coming in July
around July 17th when they revile it
inception in theatres oh really
they're trying to get people to go back
to movie theaters to the re-releasing a
ton of real I'm gonna be checking out
the really new Wonder Woman 1984 footage
from the movie so whatever it is I will
totally do a video for breaking down all
the Easter eggs to know whether or not
they're gonna post that online so you
probably wind up having to go to the
theater to see it DC is also doing a big
special virtual Comic Con event later
this summer separate sweet gladden
separate we'll get you even more hyped
up if you're already excited oh yeah
that because of the way all these movie
releases are changing Justice League is
probably gonna wind up being Warner
Brothers biggest spring early summer
movie blockbuster it's not even being
released in theaters I've already done a
couple videos about how that would be
surprised if you radically agree so I'll
link them at the Everett was it'll be a
totally different movie
and speaking of wonderful hardly
Sawyer's gonna record new dialogue for
Zack Snyder's alternate footage the new
version of the movie is going to be over
four hours long and they're saying
around 75% of that is probably to be
totally different story and footage than
the CI oh my god the dialogue that needs
to be recorded for say like the dark
side scenes who they're putting back in
the movie thankfully dark side is coming
back in the other scenes just to stitch
everything together in a way that makes
sense but right now the report is
they're going to be breaking the movie
up into six different parts and airing
it on HBO max like a miniseries next
summer so it's basically going to be
Warner Brothers biggest summer
blockbuster event no official release
date yet but it'll play B sometime
between late April to early June and it
would just run for six weeks six
different episodes if you don't have HBO
max right now I'm sure they're gonna run
some promo and they'll be dropping
Taylor's for that before the end of the
year and early next year we're having so
many problems going to connect to what's
happening in Wonder Woman 1984 the big
hope for the Justice League Snyder cut
is that if it's as successful as it
seems like it's going to be Warner
Brothers we'll just be open to
continuing that part of the DC Universe
with other types of stories and projects
like that on HBO max in the future if
they announce that they're doing the
same thing for Suicide Squad and
changing that one alternate cut of the
boat I'll do a video for that too but
thus far they've only said that they're
doing it for Justice League right now
Wonder Woman 1984 and Wonder Woman three
are only loosely connected to the
previous Justice League DC EU movies in
the sense that it's still gal gadot
playing the character in in
presentational still no Aquaman Batman
the flash cyborg superman are sure
apparently Shazam now now that should
say I met the Justice League before the
ending of that movie with the strap mat
acknowledged that minimal DC movies
going forward is there letting the
directors do more self-contained movies
if they want
so some of the DC movies going forward
will still be connected to Justice
League and some will not two great
examples that on opposite ends of the
spectrum are damn two in the Batman
movie with Robert Pattinson so if you
didn't see the news a while ago Henry
Cavill is signing a contract to come
back a Superman Man of Steel in the DC
Universe but crossing over into other
upcoming DC movies he's not signing a
contract for Man of Steel to one of the
movies he would cross over into would be
Shazam - I'll do a new Superman movie
video sometime soon - because Superman
movie and when Warner Brothers is
playing on actually doing that on the
opposite end of the spectrum in terms of
continuity the Batman movie with Robert
Pattinson is not going to be connected
to justice league is supposed to be a
prequel version of Ben Affleck's Batman
number 2 the new Wonder Woman 1984 stuff
is mostly about Wonder Woman and
cheetahs character arc the way that
they're sitting at cheetah for possible
future returns and other DC movies or
even Wonder Woman 3 so this is basically
what cheetah looks like in the movie
there been a Coco Mo's that had been
released of what she actually looks like
at various points during the film but
the whole idea is that she slowly
becomes cheetah over the course of the
film so she evolves into the comic book
cheetah form and it actually does look
pretty good on screen Maxwell Lord is
the closest thing to a main film the
movie has but even he isn't really a
villain in the way that Ares God of War
was the main villain of the first Wonder
Woman movie if you're going into the
movie kind of expecting the end to be
similar to the first Wonder Woman movie
you will be extremely surprised the
movie could not be more different Kloss
rewatch the trailer a couple times
notice what's missing from all the
scenes Wonder Woman does not have her
sword with her in present-day and even
when she puts on the special war armor
with the gold wings from the comics she
doesn't have the sword and she doesn't
have healed
at any point during the trailer just the
lasso of truth patty Jenkins and gal
gadot said that she's not using those
the shield or the sword in the movie
because she isn't going to be running
around chopping body parts off of anyone
no gods
no regular people no metahumans not even
cheetah or Maxwell Lord and it's all
part of
the idea that the movie isn't supposed
to be about Wonder Woman defeating
villains or fighting villains it's all
about how wonderful minute saves
everyone or at least tries to save
everyone like one the whole thing with
the cheetah story or friends because
Barbara Minerva thinks of herself as
trash she wants nothing more than to
have what she perceives to be Wonder
Woman's power and grace she wants to be
Wonder Woman because of what Maxwell
Lord does with a special black stone
that becomes Daniel II possible for her
so cheetah effectively gains 42
abilities and becomes powerful like
Wonder Woman over the course of the
movie but in the movie because this is
all about the excess and greed of the
80s it's about the metaphors of greed
turning people into monsters but because
it's a comic book movie and you have a
special magical black rock it also
literally turns people into monsters so
that explains how that's a pretty gnarly
in terms of her coming back in future DC
movies that would either be Wonder Woman
3 or another DC movie but they haven't
said specifically which one it's just
the idea that she could always come back
at Kristen Wiig wants to come back like
I said though the big special new
footage that they're releasing for
Wonder 1 1984 that'll be sometime around
July 17th when they re released
inception in theaters they'll be
dropping a bunch of footage for upcoming
main if we don't get an in July sometime
between the movie where do you go to
show up again there's a bunch of stuff
coming up in the next Nider but
everything is possible as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all those videos when I post
them but leave all your at rest in the
comments below
everyone click here spider-man
Miles Morales trailer thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight see ya but
that wasn't expecting cheater to look so
white I know yeah cheetahs are normally
white I mean it looks like a human
cheetah yeah the color pattern even in
the comics is not so more Orange
it's not that white yeah Bart I agree
adapt it of course to make it look more
real from the images I've been getting
they've been like daylight images yeah I
feel like to pull off a cheetah look
should be a night mean you have some
sequences in the trailer are obviously
taking place during night time even when
she's wearing the fancy ass armor that
is at nighttime so perhaps like the
craziest fight will be going down at
nighttime so that way the effects on
cheetah will look the best because I
feel like for that level of visual
effects I don't think it's practical
makeup although that would be the
preferred method I don't think that are
gonna be doing that especially for like
transformation sequences and whatever
very curious see how it's gonna look in
motion and if it's gonna come across
goofy on-screen Wonderwoman fighting a
cheetah but on the flipside somatically
hearing what they want to do with it
because I never noticed that she doesn't
have the sword yeah she only has like
the lasso primarily focusing more on her
actually being like a hero for the
people saving lives and such kind of
like the beginning of Justice League
Joss Whedon cut whatever that high
sequence was but yeah capitalizing more
on her actually being a hero come to
think about it I'm like we don't really
focus on that as much anymore in
superhero movies our heroes are forces
to be reckoned with who are just as
powerful as the evil thing that is
3-axis I think a lot of the time yeah we
just it's kind of I don't know if it's a
quaint thing people don't care as much
about or if it's an afterthought but
it's something that's actually kind of
bugged me about recent superhero movies
kind of like a perfunctory thing of oh
yeah there are people or maybe nowadays
because of stuff like Man of Steel
they're like well there's no people here
well you can just like some kind of
random line of dialogue and I don't know
if you always feel like it's more
tangible when there's a sense that the
regular folks need saving well penny
Jenkins is heavily inspired by Richard
Donner's a Superman movie in which
there's an obvious scene in there that
pays direct homage to that film in that
78 flick when Superman has a little bit
of a montage or sequence of events where
he's just saving people who you know
he's just being a hero on the streets I
feel like capturing that spirit again in
that tone yeah the no man's land scenes
on the most beautiful things I've seen
in any comic book movie brings me to
tears every time bringing her more
closer to modern day I mean it's still
like 36 years capturing that spirit
again and that
of saving people will be cool and plus
the I might just look a little weirder
she's like slicing and dicing all these
like regular people
actually I really like that conceptually
just as even a visual cue I never like
you said caught that your sword and
shield weren't being utilized and I
think that's an interesting way to kind
of challenge yourself as a maker of
superhero films this should go okay
what's the in wonder woman's repertoire
that's iconic because the last of truth
super iconic but also that is a little
different in terms of what we're used to
fighting with what used to using you
know as our delivery system for these
messages to because I imagine with a
device like that you know she's
literally fighting with truth and sure
in a time and place where again you know
even though yeah it is removed from time
80s nostalgia is huge and we also live
in a time where truth and the legitimacy
of truth are really important and so I
feel like that could actually be a
really timely thing to do with this is
yeah lead with that wasn't purchasing
awesome in this video saying that
justice Lee 22 the Snyder cut will be
the biggest movie of DC come next year
or summer because another movie they
moved the Batman to next year I'm still
under the impression the Batman would be
bigger than the Snyder Code Justice
League office they're not runtime
whatever but I think in terms of people
tuning in audience interest worldwide I
still feel like it would be the Batman
more than Justice League 2021 cuz it's
like you could be a total newbie to all
this and want to see the Batman
yeah you might be like still a whole
little bit misinformed what the hell's
going on yeah I mean to me that kind of
balance each other out because you have
yeah just the mass appeal of Batman you
take all these rumors but then you have
the Snyder code which is just such a
cinematic anomaly at this yeah I think
that like people who I bet swore off
even watching it before are probably
interested now that reals so yeah I was
a little curious about the way that that
was worded partly too because I was like
isn't that coming out like the beginning
of next year yeah so much summer time
but I can definitely see it being one of
their most significant releases of that
year one thing that I do want to say in
terms of what they're doing for
additional photography on that movie
because reportedly
they're not having anyone really come
back on screen it's all gonna be like
voiceover of work to rework at all when
you have it in the hands of Zach
Schneider regardless what you think of
his films terms of visuals he excels at
that so you know he can pull it off
without having to worry about actors
coming back in 300 I was like you had
just like green screens if at that at
best
well even Sucker Punch which was not one
was most beloved pieces of work is
primarily visual effects if they have to
do most of this primarily with visual
effects I'm like well Zack Snyder is one
of the few directors I actually trust to
make it work you know and in a way that
feels natural to what he's aiming for
you 75% of that is a lot I mean some of
that I really wonder how they're gonna
have to do it because you know I mean
darkside is gonna have to involve a lot
of effects for sure if that and yet it
also just goes to make you wonder what
all did they and then Wonder Woman
getting pushed back what's gonna own an
October oh yeah like that's a great
month for it to come out I think it's
better than August in a lot of ways it's
like it might not be summer
I think comic book movies have proven to
be great hits in October venom Joker and
I could do Wonder Woman and granted
those ones are promoted at least for
venom in the darker realm where Joker
was definitely darker I still think
Wonder Woman 84 in October is not a bad
call at all lieutenant getting pushed to
weeks it's worried for Nolan's sanity I
feel like he's gonna get pushed again I
really really feel like and I wonder
yeah what that's gonna mean for him for
this because you know what if we get to
a point where October looks if yeah
because the one thing that is fortunate
for these films is like Wonder Woman 84
any of these that were supposed to come
out this year I think they're all gonna
do it doesn't matter what doesn't matter
when they come out no matter when
because yeah they're like the only
they're the movies in the chamber ready
to go and no matter what when their
industry starts back up there's gonna be
a lurch you know as long as it's not
September or January I feel like those
any other month you're fine yeah we're
ramping into like you know awards season
and the end of the year were like you
know all the memorable stuff arguably is
wanting to go so who knows October they
usually reserved horror films they're
for obvious reasons
but beyond that it's not like most
horribly come in October don't horrible
health you know maybe it'll be a body
horror with Kristen Wiig slowly
transforming I could see that into the
cheetah and I could see if they could
see that they're talking about possibly
building her up and to me it's like the
way everything's being formulated it
sounds like Maxwell Lord would be the
one who's built up to be more in one
room and three and cheetah would be the
one who like goes out in part two that's
the way I take it but maybe that's where
they're gonna subvert your expectations
yeah yeah make Pedro Pascal a [ __ ]
totally useless character turns out
cheetah was it all along part three
she'll be the big battle of wonder woman
universe a man
then she'll first dark side and also uh
you know the flash with the new moons of
this off
I forgot my the release date thing sure
Wonder Woman was always gonna come out
it's at least coming out in 2020 yeah
whereas the flash just they keep saying
it's happening but it's not that's the
New Mutants of the DC Universe I'll
believe it when I see it right guys well
what do you think of this news what do
you think this cheetah looks isn't the
first time I'm seeing it subscribe to
the real rejects subscribe to emergency
awesome if you haven't done so already
click the notification bug and notify
don't forgot new YouTube video last but
not least well this Wonder Woman talk
it's only appropriate we shout out a
female patron and today is Adelia
Chamberlain
hi Delia happy belated birthday I don't
think we wished you a happy birthday
last month so I'm gonna cover my ass
here say happy belated birthday sounds
we had a wonderful dinner some chicken
parm got to have some nice time with
your family I want to encourage you to
get some more sleep last time we talked
you're sitting only average like six
hours of sleep at night now you just
turned 25 years old it's better to get a
head start start getting some extra
sleep while you're at it some rest
another thing you've been a wonderful
contribution in terms of helping me
study for the movie trivia Schmo down
thank you so much for sending over those
notes slice chatted me out on Twitter
after my last match you're so awesome
you know you bring a lot of wonder to my
life as well one day when I see you in
person in your home state I'm gonna run
to you like a cheetah and bow your feet
as if you're a Maxwell Lord slap a
little lasso truth around me and I'll
come on to you and really offer way you
usually into that scent then you use the
god killer on me
and cut me up and then you'll bury me
but then Batman and flash will use their
powers to resurrect me see what I'm
doing I'm type you are the DCAU the DC
Adelia universe that's what I want I
know you're more of a Marvel fan
Thank You Adelia